dans pourquoi on dit je vous raconte ce
qui se cache derrière les expressions de
la langue française alors abonnez vous
et n'oubliez pas que je suit loches
salue les épées curieuse et les épis
curieux pourquoi disons nous que nous
brûlons que nous coincer la bulle comme
une faisons rien
[Musique]
ce sont les militaires qui sont à
l'origine de cette expression au milieu
du 20ème siècle la précision d'un tir
d'artillerie nécessité que la plateforme
de l'engin soit à l'horizontale à
l'époque pas de gps ni de laser les
militaires utilisent et un niveau à
bulle
il ajustait jusqu'à ce que la bulle soit
coincé entre les deux petits traits une
fois l'opération réussie
ils attendaient les ordres et en dansant
il ne faisait rien si ce n'est jeté un
oeil sur la bulle pour vérifier qu'elle
était bien point c'est d'où l'expression
bull et pour coincer la bulle
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]